hello everyone welcome to Thursdays at a
lunchtime stream how is everyone doing
today
about the only after playing a load of
war zone and trying to
finally really weird weapons and
people's pickups these are a bit odd so
I decided to kind of set a challenge up
that we're gonna try and win a round of
war zone using ugliest weapons possible
I don't have everything unlocked but
I've spent a little time trying to make
either really hideous weapons or weapons
that are no doubt going to be absolutely
useless and so this is what I've come up
with so far and please feel free to
leave your suggestions of absolutely
terrible weapons that we can start using
but this is we'll go through a couple of
them this is definitely one of my works
of art get out of here so we have the m4
smoke launcher no stock
and a variable sniper scope I can't
imagine this is going to be very good
but we're gonna use it anyway and we
also have this horrid mp5 with the
thermal rounds so you've got range here
but then with the short barrel and the
collapsible stock you're not gonna get
any range out of it so that'll be
interesting to use my personal favorite
is the weapon that I've called long boy
because it's it takes up the entire
screen it's huge it's this bright gold
Odin and I've put every attachment on it
that makes it longer so it's like when
you see it in my character's hands at
the other lobby it's bigger than them
almost and so basically we gotta jump
into some games and try and eke out an
awkward
I mean I'm we're not gonna win ever have
to we're not gonna run around of these
things but we're gonna try so as soon as
I get the loadout crates hey Sean how's
it going they get a loadout crate I'll
be picking one of these terrible
terrible weapons to to go forward with
so that'd be fun
which editing software do I use I use
Adobe Premiere Pro
how's everyone doing today oh my me turn
off my
your things it's making weird flashes
Jaxon's do we see look how long this
thing is
it's massive well Shawn you're obviously
a very good
for sharing some videogames with your
siblings during this time of need a
great gaming world I use ohto I've heard
of it
when I first taught myself at anything I
used Sony Vegas but well while the
transition to Premiere Pro is rough it
was worth it
so our first objective is to a survive
long enough to get a load out drop and
then be yeah a low drop get one of the
grim weapons that I was showing off and
if honestly if I can get a kill with
every one of them for me that's mission
accomplished that's that's a decent goal
to how I think I think if we quit ago
for the Odin first actually well we'll
see what the situation is okay well
everyone's having such intense
difficulties getting the
updates like I had to leave my computer
running all night to get the update Sean
I am one of the creators that work
against pop I didn't found the sitemap
17 Rocko plays oh right um where should
we go
I don't really actually know the maps
well enough to know this is a really
good tactical drop yada yada yada so I'm
just gonna go to the end of promenade
Oh Shawn I'm I'm just one of the guys
that makes some of the videos hello
gamespot has been around for decades why
not get any ammo with that give me an
Odin and no ammo oh good Oh Thank You
Rocco yeah I was apparently if you I
change your server region where is this
box
um truth in the Installer that's up here
that can kind of help I'll take an
unknow satchel I think I found the same
before that's how it works for me Jackie
I downloaded the quality update from the
Asia server and it wasn't blisteringly
fast but it went from 500 kilobytes to 6
Meg that point I was like yeah I'll take
it
sure why not
I don't think I want this care
especially since the Odin has a bit
arranged here already okay cable then
yeah you're not sure you can change
server regions an Xbox can you that is
the answer I'll just let you carry more
armor okay think they just added that
item in because I have not seen it
before and playing on my personal
computer of it and not whenever I want
Rocco it's it's more we all like
scheduled streams Persia will take some
some streams during the American hours
and I usually do Tuesdays and Thursdays
around this time but if I'm gonna if I
want if I get the edge to stream I'll do
it my own twitch yeah let's go for that
I love you too you know where I'm at now
and and again again the shield chapter
it just just because just because we
don't have a kill streak yet I'm just
playing solos today I'm afraid me but
I'm a regular Dave on battlenet and I
did community games sometimes so maybe
we'll squad up then no use this to Roman
to see if I can see anyone
gunshots over here that's why it
that's a bird
there really isn't many people near me
oh there's someone I mean the miles away
I'm not gonna get to them but well we've
we've just started so can you break oh
my god I've not actually found the
challenge weapons yet - you don't have
to sit I need to get enough cash so I
can call in a loadout that's not running
towards oh hello guy ye thank you all
right can I call in a well save will
save will save up you will get another
thousand now we know where the shop is
or a loaded rifle and I've seen you say
a thousand isn't exactly get up here
a huge ask can I climb across these
things I'll tell mr. gasps master though
you hero I'll come back and gather
do you did you mean mummy oh no it's
right there
sorry I ever doubted you so sort of UAV
Johnny ghost hair of the hour coming in
clutch thank you very much I'll head
towards the edge of the map if they can
find another grand let's just go for
that all right let's go fer let's go for
the long gross Odin to start with oh
hello guys this is a weapon that I have
named long boy because I think it might
be the longest weapon in the game
I could see the Odin which is already
quite long with the longest barrel and a
Colossus suppressor
I'm not shortly honestly matheus um I
know that touch with the bundles and
stuff recovered you it's a minute
unfortunately I think I'm full armor me
um I'm armored up don't you worry about
me it's the map saying to keep Jessica
head towards the edge
oh the p90 is extremely long especially
with the extended barrel in it but this
thing is if you see the characters hold
it on the on the screen it's it's like
as long as they are
I'm not mean I'm the lovely human being
you're right Johnny I should go and get
those items ten percent there's a shot
this way you can see it look at my
shadow look how long is it's bright gold
as well might as well just be wearing a
huge beacon telling everywhere
oh no no no okay let's let's get it
still got 2,700 left as well honestly
not sure matheus fingers crossed right
although to be fair I bought the season
pass and I've still yet to unlock my
attack dog
so my that's my next goal I think where
is everyone
what about Phoenix I'm not sure what you
mean with Froy friend I've the wrong end
of the stick
see I've got whenever I've got UAV I
never really want to use it on my car
save it for the last circle I'll save it
until I know there's someone nearby I'll
end up just getting killed with it scary
noise
it's these supply caches we can a few
more bucks I don't want a flash I'm a
harpy sensor oh hello I saw you
yeah well there's some over here a song
parachute down can't remember if this
loadout keep me safe from guess we'll
find out Johnny you're a pro game and my
friend advice
gross
well it's up in that way all right I'll
take your vices puppet it's tempting I
was going to try and shoot the pilot
while his flight good good tips good
tips and DS Oh like I shouldn't have
rushed that shot
no there's someone up there list hello
men are you sat right there
also it cares to me that maybe just
sitting here isn't the best idea right
on the open have to try and find a shop
then huh
yeah he's still up there he's aiming at
me
no I didn't wanna fall down
no oh I got a head shot me I think I got
the self of I've no doubt I'm oh I can't
believe I got rinse with the chopper
blade oh no mister believe that's a
sterling advice understand I'm terrible
the Gulag as well this is the end of all
Dave hello ion you think we can get back
to where I died why did I die what was
it it was right there
I just get all my old kit back beautiful
some something is has fallen down go
back there oh I can't believe I missed
again are you Aldo but I think he's got
to survive to get the chopper get the
chopper see you later
oh we got a revenge chat yeah I did see
yeah I did see the cash I will try and
get that although I don't think it's
over necessary we've got quite a lot
here after this kill as well take your
gold gun my friend now is he gonna do
the same thing as me win the Gulag and
then rush back to me
self-rising cluster strike right where's
the nearest shop gonna steal this guy's
chopper
you're gonna get plus a strike self
revive the advice of chat then we're
gonna go back oh that's very cheeky
I know Oh
choppers gone I'll try get some high
ground on this guy ever ever is I don't
know if that was the guy just killed
trying to come back and get his revenge
it does a lot for me I just realized I
don't have my perks cuz I lost my
loadout I only came back and got the
weapons I try and get my perks back
oh it's a scary
see it bottle up the Odin
give me your hacking money long boys
company clutch
all right well circles coming in I think
we can just play it good and slow Reza
gas-mask I guess I better go snobby good
I'd better yeah
I'm talk anymore don't get caught in the
gas Dave that's what I was trying to say
oh that's naughty
don't kill me don't kill me come now
Joestar who lose the streaming service
I'll take ninth
I'll take ninth after that William the
Odin is my favorite gun in the game it's
the right stuff on it there's a lot of
damage it's pretty controllable it's got
a really good range I love it it's it's
just in situations like that where the
fire rate is a little bit on the slow
side that it can be a bit rough with you
if you if you're landing head shots and
body shots then any grand
captain hunter hello
all right well I think that was like the
least like look at the size this gun
this is the least weird gun we have in
our armory so let's get the horrendous
gross and for tomorrow it's more why
aren't you in bed
it's so late where you are good luck
with school I on get that gray matter
working yeah
yeah the Odin I use last match this
match I've got a gross awful awful em
for that it might be fun to try news
well thank you mr. Walid I realize it's
my lead not mr. Willy but now I'm
imagining that you are like a successful
businessman or something love you to
town
sleep well I think I'll use the 80 inch
barrel on the Odin just then but
normally if I'm not doing stupid
challenges are you to use the the middle
biggest sixty around sixty inch barrel
and the 3.4 L Co site or something and a
Colossus suppressor that's all so big
sake the boy thick boys suppressor
all right get gun get some money get a
load out get the goods
Battle Royale
avoids a gas can't do the SafeZone me
let's go let's go
madmen and your military base actually
now we're gonna go there
it finishes it 2:00 p.m. burritos dad
it's not just Naruto a universe' I do
like the UK hours stream yeah no I
didn't want to I'll take the phallus
that's will play a lot of grass if since
we're after pee night all right
good start Thank You Naruto I will
certainly be doing my best
I've got 2 1 1 2 days so that would be
nice
our Theoden my love
and half life half boxer old old game my
friend much as it pains me to say that
because I played it when I was a kid
I love the little Russian Burger town
logo come on you got to be better than
that son you got to be better than that
and a pistol with me I'm not gonna lie
Joestar I don't know who that is
I'm not down with the kids let's hit a
by station then we'll get the UAV and
then maybe just wait for the loadout to
come in naturally it literally just flew
into my bullets that guy huh just
delivered himself to me it was a little
annoying you see not a couple of armored
plates off me but I don't what are you
shotguns my friend not bit I'm not big
fan of shotguns
my other gun it's the p90 right yes oh
right in the middle we can just go
wandering pretty much any direction we
like them
if I had ever had any firearm experience
in real life yes I shot a number of real
real weapons
[Music]
I think I can get on them I've got I've
got a couple plates I'm okay for now
famous last words I know but trying to
save my money's for a load ready go
whoa I'm scared I'm reloading have a lot
okay and said the RPG thanks stopping by
William my favorite gun in this Call of
Duty or in like the history of Call of
Duty Marotta I can't even win a solo
game do you think i can win solo squads
appreciate the PA the props but I don't
see my friend
I mean go for it skins help
hey maybe ever so slightly I don't I
don't think there's so much help as some
of them probably hinder I there are some
that are easily easier to notice like
bright colors or we go the [ __ ] off but
at the range where maybe otters ghillie
suit might give you an advantage I don't
think that bushes are even gonna be
rendering so in war zone
I really like my Odin build there's so
many long sightlines in war zone and
that got that guns really good at medium
to long range back it up with an SMG or
you want to go even further long range
with a cheeky sniper rifle what's good
right we're gonna go for this and you
know for all the loadout drops if we
haven't got one we need them to do a
silly little challenge ad stand out you
do send up but I suppose you should eat
things I mean any barrel it's not not so
much fun just people watching corners is
it alright I'm sorry chat but we're
gonna get the awful now I got stuck at
the menu alright I'll get it
I'll try and go back I built all these
awful weapons to try and mix things up
in war zone
so we need to try and get one s in chat
big s
six I read it up looking forward to
using that wall for
Maxo fission you really need to fix the
Welsh flag in this game month please for
me enough a dragon's head for pete's
sake
you
I made up my mind I just froze up so I
was getting shot by P night I knew
exactly was gone I wanted mr. Prince
while I was in the bow menu but that's
fine
ah
you
hello from good hello India are you
doing AC valhalla
sign times right intriguing to you watch
the entire art stream
I haven't even unlocked the crossbow
that bear kills in the lobby than I do
in game so yeah they want my least
favorite guns in the game
I think I think I checked in on the
stream like every 90 minutes so I guess
every now and again I've ever added a
cool new thing it's definitely an
interesting way to tease all right at
least get one of our deaf guns this
round
our faith
oh by the circle is starting small this
might be a in front of the edge of it
never actually been to the prison today
is not the day
maybe we should start a starting lumber
and try and rush our way in we don't
have to go to the circle right now
while my pc specs 32 gigabyte of RAM 2
Nvidia 1080s and sli knows the important
bits right how am i tracked already
please leave me be good oh good
hey I'd love to make a bolter I've been
painting Boulter's all weekend actually
oh sweet
in fact complete is the riot shield any
good cuz I've never actually used it
like it just makes me stand out I'm just
seeing a giant cube running across the
map
yeah that's why I figure if anyone's got
like c4
any explosives Alice they have mostly
been doing a death guard so it's been a
lot of greens and gross cutters still
people around here and I knows it
I don't think he's gunshot he's still in
there or well I think he ran out the
back
we don't know where he is now so he's a
scary situation counter-strike and
half-life that's a certainly a bold take
firing an antique yeah I suppose Emma I
really an antique that someone's stuck a
reflex sight on those heathens all right
our gear ain't great but it's let's get
in the circle and try and make something
happen shall we
I realize that so far I sigh - I should
have probably probably got on that quad
bike I do like how the war zone map
combines a lot of ground war maps I
think that's the mode I mostly play in
mana warfare
oh hello all right wait for him to get
on the open ice hits why so he's not
gonna peek us if he's clever those
I was trying to run him over
[Music]
except I've no idea where he's gone
it was set up here ah there it is well
I'm gonna get you sir
I don't know I don't think I've played
quite enough to know the ins and outs
just yet
don't repeat me come on now it's a silly
thing to do wasn't it
and this is a gross gun - damn Rose
we've ditched the antiques you don't
have to worry about the have to worry
about that anymore
this is a lot of open ground to cover
this me nervous
come on let me place the thing it's too
late once try and get close enough to
throw some c4 at it in some situations
yeah I should take a car but there are
times where I feel like it just tells
everyone where I am you know
so thermite just in case I see another
truck in the circle now so we can take
the edge off a little bit a front-flip
that last time I don't know okay all
right maybe we don't rush towards the
load out dry this time let's give it
let's give it a second simmer down
give a safe chat should we go for it all
right we're gonna get an awful gun and I
can only apologize for putting you
through this I'm trying to get the
sniper rifle where's it gone come on
don't do me like this oh no oh this guns
are awful I act so in case you missed it
this is an m4 with no stock a sniper
scope the smallest barrel and a smoke
launcher you don't think this is that's
an awful gun Kobe and it's a to you
consider a good gun then and yeah it's
bright bright pink and everyone can see
you with it
gosh to try and go for this car ready
but of course exactly what you need with
a for a gun with no stock and a sniper
scope as a 60 round magazine
[Music]
I think if you hit them the smoke
launcher it does do damage alright let's
get it do you think the gun is good with
this one should miss Cruz move I mean
that that is usually when you've got a
weapon that's like doing a long-range
engagement but it's a short good range
gun or if you're me you just choke get
yourself killed
you'd actually have gross sniper rifle
as well
get through the windows
so my drone saw him over there right
look at our Benjamin apex for now for
ground war war zone buddy war zone I
used to play a lot of fortnight I played
a bunch of apex and I came out too but I
kind of bounced off it quite quickly but
for me this this this game is the best
quality in years and I think back of
what what did you get compare it up
against
then actually realize how low of armored
plates I was put out a few definite
situation we need to address them as
this screw let's just go to the next own
preventative measures my car resist
checking this I don't have armor in it
no that's where we had
little jewel up there with our old
sniping friend
I'm nervous now I've realized how few
armor plates I have that's pretty satin
scared
actually never did place in so every
Drive are you don't you're not gonna
like this kilo or this gun it's weird by
thing I don't like the kilo I can hear
someone fudge Oh literally as I was
getting up it's time
that was close
all right sir this is sticky situation
now don't imagine there's gonna be a lot
of loot laughter little Dave right 500
buckaroos 75 in an RPG and a dream and
now I can't I can't tell you something
survive with two bullets that won't kill
a fully armored person big beams David
big memes someone after a couple of bits
for me that was awful kind of them I
think the best bet is to maybe just take
the chopper somewhere where do we go I
have to push him definitely have to push
him he's got no mama
oh my goodness gracious made us close
keep the RPG it's in case stuck the
power rounds we've on that me one gravy
bountiful itself I've kit that's fine
that's not fine it's terrifying but it's
fine
yeah finding on my mouse aim into a
place where I feel comfortable with it
that now enough for a self revive what
this one has cash in tight tight tight
tight tight tight tight
I really want to leave now
I think I won again the trees and the
hills with this I've got the long range
my luck I'll land on someone now now as
a known and I'm so far away from people
thinks bet saved at the minute I've got
seven shields I'm good for shields now
thankfully it's scary before with my
shields and a wait for the ring to close
and then I'm gonna get a few goodies
that's what some of us sniped love eben
around in this final circle huh Oh Nelly
lobbying an owl that made me jump that's
very lucky shot from this direction and
I need to go back there not fan of that
that's it that's rightful because he was
hitting me from range he back son
though now where did you go I see a
source Clint I think right round in this
view but I'm gonna go back and get the
awful weapon is I mean that's the whole
point of the stream right even the HDR
and probably sense though
this is just outside the zone innovative
people in my every building right oh my
days behind bay
that's good sure his party right now
we've had a ninth and an eighth so if we
place seven more games well then one
that's right
it's fine I forgive you the next weapon
will try and go for then is do we want
to do the awful a K or the gross mp5 but
you guys think
about pistol I'm just in case
you
well I suppose we've got plenty of time
to actually figure out
you open for another game first is any
mp5 Apollo 10 B 5 the big scope and
don't you be tiny barrel
Thank You Koby I'll bet I'll bear that
in mind next time
be open so much I gotta get somewhere
comfy but yeah that guy was right on the
edge with their circlets back I wasn't
looking back there no plane well shot me
dead on twice
some Conte
so gamers yes stateless Welsh flag guys
lethal very offended
as the mission a just get a couple kills
get some cash getting all four mp5 I get
kill with it I mean I'm happy that I
said if as long as we get one kill with
every awful weapon I've made I'm gonna
consider that a victory and we had to
that's one is some way
big a a gun
challengin in the loading loving some
huh okay
I don't know the map well enough to
think I was good to drop it think
militaries in military base that's real
spicy damn
that's what go downtown London a roof of
somewhere actually hospital just because
that was one of my favorite drops in
budget
but watch me get absolutely rinsed here
now
oh boy I scared them away sorry Britt
not too keen on the lever action you
know rinse wash repeat at me pretty much
that's the SDM the game right that's one
of the things I like a lot about war
zone is that is so easy to jump back
into a game and start doing fun things
again but some games like pub G was you
put a lot of effort in and then you died
real quick and then it took a lot of
effort to actually play the game again
is this because it's cool seem exactly
seeing how much shopping again hit so
why not go somewhere with loads of meds
or he's lucky he's a lucky boy it might
be the guy just killed returning from a
gulag spree lice had a little mo I have
this energy so here
he's right in here you happy sensor
happy sensor is a bit busted huh I've
never actually played the blender son
you know I thought I'd had the complete
hey hun set me on fire I throw a rock
and helped you
now where on earth do we go
we can we go back to hospital might be a
risk but that guy kind of taken all that
new
let's go for this roof first just in
case third gun up here now let's risk it
all there's a truck there maybe this is
a stupid idea
I built my career on stupid ideas so how
was it literally a backpack to the exact
place we died all right it's like
nothing happened except we lost loads of
money and a whole lot on the plates
is that the guys that killed me last I
mean probably the shotguns are good in
the right hands I don't think my hands
like I just choke and end up missing all
my shots when I use the shotguns I mean
keep the heartbeat sensor I think rather
than the gas grenade it's cuz the things
so damn strong in this mode as playing
modern warfare 2 the other day to get
some gameplay capture remember when you
could just mount that thing on the side
of your gun what time that was
you're right John revenge after the kill
sneaky boy enemy oh yeah just come
through that door
that's you like it here should get the
load out drop for the means
and said the mp5 that's what again it's
a very gross mp5 topic god that's
startled me and when I doing community
games today mr. in the real YouTube
gaming by respecting some claim would be
doing community games then teamed up the
chat how do I get to the top of the
building it
I'm warzone David all done he little
battery out okay she goes this shop as
well
my targets down there somewhere I was
him I produced be waiting to all blows
[Laughter]
eat my c4 thinks I can't see him you die
please oh you're lucky
what a lucky boy if I'd hit that last
show though that would chefs kiss
stick out like a sore thumb up here
right and I got them off that roof I
suppose you definitely didn't to stay
there much longer
that's still
bangle you're gonna reap eek I don't if
you saw me I'm a knight
yeah you definitely saw me over here
delicious
oh he's back did he suffer both is it
different well I know you want to repeat
that angle but it just have a look have
a quick look I know you're curious come
on what's up there he's thinking I can I
can win this exchange he's thinking it's
important when you land a shot
thank you David to a maneuver ELISA
little bit so they can't pre-aim
right hear me out well my goodness that
was lucky timing
I was not my intention I'll take it I
was gonna try and jump in the helicopter
and throw c4 at this guy
solo not ideal that I'm being hunted as
well now oh stop moving
as you know that I hit him from this
angle
ha stop it now that guy's shooting me
again
any from all angles all of a sudden how
is how is this not I mean this is the
weirdest weapon and I've just basically
put awful attachments together to kind
of up the challenge a little bit but the
minute you're in a sniper fight with
whoever's over there I was going to take
that shot I'm basically just trying to
clear some rooftop so I can move every
rooftop has a human on it plus it's fun
snipe as the circle closes are to switch
back to the mp5 no doubt
priest sheep in me running up top here
honest
oh no I thought the safe zone was gonna
go the other way but the situation is no
longer ideal think that you're over you
can see me too
you think we can get back up to the top
of this building or do we think
someone's in there someone's up here I
don't just heard it it's gonna shoot me
as I got bit no I do
Oh God
terrified me
I think he was going for a assassination
take them thing oh wow
just turned around he was sneaking right
there oh dear babe good on him good I am
sneaking
for name
we'll try and use the gross stockless
okay now it's basically only usable if
you mount it
back to the weird tiny pocket sniper m4
or the Odin
and loads of gross
Paul
old man ha this was the m4 was the m4
we're using without the with no stock
not exactly what you'd call tactical
yes this knife to practice will be
deployed so we went from 8 to 7 to 23rd
an ideal swallow
all right let's hope we can get the
goods we've been after
I know it's only warm-up that are still
cool doesn't matter where you go no
scope is so cool oh wow this isn't small
circles maybe I'll wait and go to prison
I've not been to prison before
non-game anyway
Battle Royale
it's miserable day out here
gamespot branded war [ __ ]
okay first prison drop let's see how it
goes
wanna grab ooh
I agree Johnny the far sizes seems to be
getting more and more bizarre I
literally have to uninstall a bunch of
stuff from my harddrive to play call of
duty now I don't even want to know how
big that the total 5 side file sizes
one is back towers maybe or someone
Scott tada this is what we
he's gonna come down that other or just
jump down
or map priests
we could wait forever for that that
seems less fun me tracking me for me I'm
not done nothing wrong
how is a house the fasting going no no
no don't shoot me interact as it is I've
got our plates
stuck in this tiny room it's a sniper
looking at me is all bad
you gotta move you got stuff come on
give me an angle and it's gonna sway
come this way that misplaced my chance
go up there and there's a guy over here
I'm not gonna hit that let's go try
secure this area then we're gonna bug
out on the chopper have a mind to count
us a war bang through a tent like I'm
not gonna complain yes I think
everyone's missing doing the fun outside
activities in a minute but luckily
there's some fun indoor ones we can all
do yeah it's for the best
I believe that guy didn't absolutely
melt us
why didn't I drop this drop stuff it me
[Applause]
bread site lucky me I do love the Oden
but I'm not gonna take that one because
already got a heavy machine in my
machine inside of a machine gun all
right I'd want to leave the prison now
as I'm sure every prisoner does what was
I just hit with really just a bed for
blood my chopper it just filled me
bullets I'm fat weight that guy is a
mass on point you spray it you spray in
I always try to spray people in the
gulag because that means you can see
them a little easier
71st eighth seventh 23rd and 71st we're
getting worse all right I'm gonna do one
more and then your boy needs to get some
lunch in him and I'm also editing a Call
of Duty video today so look out for that
this weekend
you didn't want to laugh again Sean so
you're just like yeah see above
respective
Iowa mAh
you know we'll go for the ugly Odin
again seems to be the one that served
its best
how long is Xena
[Music]
across the screen should edit that so I
could just push a button on my stream
deck and it pops up
good idea Ashley
face ice can get on your nerves my
friend sir get some gear weapons we go
gamers that can use the 75 sniper slugs
what is your secret I take the slugs of
this thing is this
it was buckshot anyway hear me
by the travel time is bullies weeks
why don't I just scream you don't have
to watch it sailing there's plenty of
other content on GameSpot calm there's
something else that you'd find more
entertaining I won't be offended
all right but I got in prison again that
was a bad time
why don't we let's drop over here get
guns get car Broadway
that's the game plan as it as it stands
I'm glad I'm not the owner that heard
that Kobe freaked me out oh okay my
mistake let's that happen when you're
storing a sniper rifle and your sniper
ammo together come on
any bullets entered bullets hey Aaron
how are you hopefully after we loop this
building we'll have everything we need
everything but enough to get a wriggle
on you know grab this car and just take
it to the circle I think so we don't
have to worry about that
stop giving me that right it's not funny
try to make me use the right shield it's
not gonna happen
yeah pretty good thanks friend
pretty good you might as well take the
shields all right like anything else
that slot right now that's good I hear
it's get in the circle
oh the circle really wasn't that far
let's just get feather into the circle
that I thought we were miles away please
I cashed if Ford bus station what
someone's been here
scary 700 more buckaroos and we can get
our UAV it's not mission critical right
now though I still haven't got any snap
arounds that's dare sky stand its people
in there this you reckon this is gonna
go well for us
you're telling me no don't know if he's
still there you know I was a matter of
run out back so I'm going to assume
that's what they've done to shut
[Music]
you better run there you go
still in the car
Oh bless him you heard him get
frustrated sorry me I apologize I
actually really love when that happens
I will admit hearing people I get
frustrated and scream I know it's bad
but that's b-but shut out from somewhere
I saw the bullet was passed I didn't
have high hopes in that shot I'll be
honest but you got to try
what is that - ghosts random computers I
can't say I have oh I got stuck at a
rock stuck on a rock and there's a guy
behind me don't think he was expecting
that when he woke up this morning maybe
it was I see you mr. parachute man a hit
nothing more I've never even heard that
Kobe no idea
go go for it
that was the that was the agreement
we'll get the we'll get the gross owed
in this time we gots to go this way are
they doing like a whole meta games that
battle round now huh I'd not heard of
all this stuff
and that scared him off or just made him
mad
ah why did I do that I just oh I'm an
actual idiot
all right well accidentally bought two
kill streaks
or a waste of cash Sam and I'll see the
birds flying around and think that it's
someone parachuting in how many if I hit
that three out of five shots try these
things just think think of the think of
the clip it make jack frags I'd love
that
I'll go go well cross this awful open
just go let's just go David think about
don't ever think it you're fine you're
fine you're fine poop from a but the
bone I meant to press but at least now
if there were anything scary at me
No
okay sell for five seven five seven five
seven I'm not like this good I'm very
surprised I won that exchange it really
was a bad bad position but it was the
only one I had I was pretty much stuck
there all right we have to go get some
plates now I think you'd think because
he obviously knew that I'd herself
revive he pushed but yeah yet to push
into the open towards me so it's when
the advantage was mine armor plates for
little old me these pop the UAV
might not be the best idea to give away
my position but I thought if I got a
headshot and knocked him my plates for
me the UAV is lasts less time in warzone
they seemed to vanish so quick no idea
what position he's moved to I'm gonna
bolt I'm just gonna Eve how much how
much is a armored bundle do you think
out in the open I'm a play bundle yes
please if things are a little less scary
now your Reiko be good knowledge on the
ends these hills at the high ground as
early as I can
sticks the edge maybe whoops
that made me jump get styled so easily
in these games of course behind this
rock is out of the combat area dang it I
did not see that human Jesus sneaky
sneaky man's I'll be real with you I'm
terribly the Magnum
yeah yeah our GG's gee-gees well chat
that's my two hours of the day hope you
enjoyed thank you for hanging out
opposed some silly weapons so it's nice
to do something a little new every now
and again I'll be streaming probably
tonight on my own twitch join hangout
follow my Twitter there if you want to
do that but otherwise I'll be back here
same time on Tuesday but for now thanks
for watching stay safe look after each
other
and stay inside and play video games all
yes all right MA
see you soon